Thìa phòng viên thuộc sà viên năm, bạn điều dọc,
em bị bốn thống người dờ nước dọc,
nửa đêm bị bốn thống người theo dờ nộ.
Tạc chủ sợ viên thuốc, đại hội đồng liên thuốc,
mà tà mời, đá bầu các thình viên thuốc đồng liên thuốc,
nhẹp kì hai cho hai sấu, hai khói tán,
trong đó, viên năm, tại đất cứ vị trí này,
với số phía uống buộc, một trong tà mời,
cao nhất trong số các ứng cử viên đại dẹp cho khu vụ châu Á,
cho bình dường.
Phía nó tạm thế đại hội đậu ngày bị bốn thống người,
với sự tham dự của một trong chiến nước quốc gia thành viên liên
thuốc đủ các cách bộ phía,
đá bầu, một bốn nước thành viên hội đồng liên thuốc,
nhẹp tìa hai khói sấu, hai khói tán,
của viên năm, anh độc, các ký stand,
ira kỳ cậc, năm vi,
Mauritius, Angola, Estonia,
Slovenia, Chile, Ecuador, Italy, và Anh.
Viên năm đặt một trong tà mời phía uống hộ,
cao nhất trong nhóm chỗ Á th瘑 dường.
Đồng thời là nước chỗ Á th瘑 dương dưới nhất,
là thành viên hội đồng liên thuốc nhẹp ki hi hai khói ba,
hai khói nhằm tà đất cử, nhẹp ki hi hai khói sấu, hai khói tán,
kích qua bầu cử này, phà nãy sự tin nhẹp,
để giác cao của các thành viên niên thuốc đủ vi những cam kết
và nấu lực mạnh máy của Việt Nam về thuốc đầy,
và bảo vệ quyền con người,
cùng vi những đồng góc, sang kính của Việt Nam,
trên công việc thành viên hội đồng liên quyền nhẹp ki hi hai khói ba,
hai khói nhằm vừa qua.
Đồng thời đường này cũng thị giền sự tin tượng của công đồng quốc tế,
đối lực tham gia đồng quốc hiệu qua,
tại các cơ trẻ đặc phương,
những thành tượng của Việt Nam trong hội nhập quốc tế,
và sự ghi nhẹp về viện thiễn ngày càng được cùng cố của Việt Nam,
nhưng một thành viên tích cử lối tác tin cạnh của Việt Nam.
Họ tác và phát triển Việt Nam.
Việt Nam sẽ bắt đầu giúp kiện thành viên của Đồng nghiên quyền liên thuốc,
hai khói sấu, hai khói tán và hai một tính một,
năm hai khói sấu.